Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie new Jessica Jones
footage, the series is all going to drop in
less than 10 days so let's break it down the
cool thing about this trailer is it reveals
way more David Tennant and actually implies
that Jessica Jones worked to kill him something
terrible would happen like he has some sort
of final kill order that is implanted in everyone
it seems like they've tuned everyone's powers
down just a little bit like Jessica Jones
can fly in the comics but she's not to be
flying on TV show the purple man can affect
like a great number of people but they have
to be in certain proximity to him so if you
were to walk into the middle of Times Square
in the middle of a giant parade then yeah
I mean he would be able to affect a ton of
people at the same time but because his powers
tied the pheromones of the biological pheromone
that he gives off it something that stays
in your bloodstream that's why even though
when we pick up in episode 1 to 30 escaped
his clutches she still hallucinates him distill
a lasting psychological effectiveness pry
a little bit of his pheromones that are stuck
running through her body longer you're around
him like the deeper his pheromones will seep
into your body so you can see in the flashbacks
in the trailer just Jessica was used by him
to commit crimes for a long period of time
in the comics it was several months I don't
know if it's gonna be the same amount of time
in the TV show they might play without a little
bit it looks like Jaron Hogarth here who works
for Rand Meacham in the comic books is the
one that hires Jessica Jones because the purple
man encroaches on some of her business interests
are some of their business interests Rand
Meacham is the company that Danny ran iron
fists family owns there are a lot of iron
fist rumors going around so I'll all have
to do an iron fist video at some point that
there's still going to be doing something
with it the rumor is is that Netflix has seen
the footage of John Bernthal as the punisher
like they been filming daredevil season two
and the belief is that Netflix likes what
they see so much that they want to greenlight
up punisher series before they do iron fist
it just because the punisher fits a little
bit better into this deep powered world of
the defenders iron fist starts to take it
to this like crazy mystical territory in right
now daredevil stolen crime drama mode that
the Jessica Jones is the same thing to it's
not at all like the world of the avengers
where you have like a really fantastical stuff
happening and that's kind of where our fist
gets to but I don't I don't think that's a
big problem is and is having a hard time finding
the right director the right actors the right
cast in they already have this punisher guy
so the like okay will we have this sitting
on the bench right now so why don't we greenlight
him first so it's totally possible that we
could see like a full punisher 13 episode
series and in like a short two hour iron fist
movie and he would still be in defenders is
it's not like they're not gonna do any iron
fist of they just might change their objectives
a little the cool thing about that is is that
it just means that punisher is so awesome
that they're bumping him up the batting order
speaking of big hitters my culture was actually
talking little bit about Luke Cage it sounds
like he will have his powers when the Sears
picks up with Jessica Jones picks up with
a bigger idea that I'd I think this Jessica
Jones trailer conveys is that she's kind of
on the outside is all about working by ourselves
she needs to learn to work with the team and
Luke Cage is a big part of socializing her
again here's the big question the let let
me know in the comments would you rather see
a 13 episode punisher series Gina just like
daredevil and Jessica Jones before iron fist
and then like a two-hour iron fist movie or
would you rather see 13 episodes of iron fist
and then a two-hour punisher movie either
way the all make it to defenders and I think
of all the characters punisher in daredevil
have the best chance of making it in the movies
daredevil just the most fully formed character
they have right now just because they've had
an extra 13 episodes of her just getting to
Jessica Jones but I think once each character
gets there first season you start see them
popping up in a much other stuff no promises
on Capt.
America Civil War I think a daredevil baby
small chance of being mentioned during Capt.
America but they're already so many characters
and that so I'm not can hold my breath and
if it wasn't cleared the Capt.
America Civil War trailer is going to be attached
to Star Wars the force awakens and they just
announced that X-Men is attaching their X-Men
apocalypse trailer to that to so you'll have
to giant trailers dropping with Star Wars
I guess is good have to be enough to get us
through the holidays to January when TV comes
back Deadpool is actually opening the year
in terms of big superhero movies just because
that comes in February you guys are really
gonna like the Stan Lee cameo in that it was
actually it was in the comic con trailer so
if you are a comic con and you sought you
probably know what Stan Lee is doing but I
think they cut it out of the public trailer
that they released online there is some new
Star Wars stuff coming on Thursday but is
dropping during ABC's primetime lineup and
it's all like you know for female oriented
TV shows was plugging a feature the female
characters of the force awakens a little more
than previous trailers should be bad as I'm
hoping for more Capt.
thousand we'll talk about that more Thursday
night so be sure to subscribe to get everything
just in case you haven't seen my flash versus
zoom video from last night you can click here
to watch that and you can click here for my
Marvel playlist with all my Jessica Jones
videos.
thank you so much for watching everybody let's
high five and I'll see you guys tonight!
A